What do you think David?
>> So
this is kind of an interesting example.
If we recall back in our original
tree as to the incremental
concept learning process, we saw that
there was those do nothing bubbles,
that if a negative example does
not fit our current definition,
we wouldn't actually modify
our current definition.
Here this doesn't even fit
our current concept of a foo.
Our current concept of a foo has a brick
on top, whereas this is a wedge on top.
So this doesn't even fit, so we don't
actually need to change our concept,
it doesn't fit already.
>> Good, very good.
If the example is a negative instance,
and the current definition of
the concept already excludes it,
we don't have to do anything.